it takes a lot more than accurately
recreate in a comic book characters
outfit on the big screen to make a
superhero movie worth seeing and anyone
who's seen the terrible film version of
Captain America from 1990 noser
in terms of comic book costume accuracy
it's a 10 out of 10 for having literally
everything else be absolutely terrible
it's a negative twelve and a half
needless to say when former Marvel
Studios head of visual developments
Charlie when sat down to adapt the
classic Marvel Comics cosmic super team
the guardians of the galaxy he had a lot
more on his mind than comic book
accuracy to get the right look for the
character when in his team tried
beginning with the right words before
anything else which inform the design
process oftentimes when I'm designing or
if I'm working with other designers that
are in my department at the time it's
starting with those kind of descriptors
and more in that what do those
descriptors remind you of and so there's
just a lot of adjectives actions verbs
things anything that's sort of define
who those characters are that I want to
make sure that we always go back to that
so what process did when tape of these
relatively obscure Marvel D Lister's to
bring them into the mainstream he is
what the guardians of the galaxy almost
look like because the guardians of the
galaxy were relatively unknown
characters before the movie broke out
big in 2014 when had a lot of freedom to
explore different designs for the film's
characters and settings part of that
freedom said when came from Marvel
Studios chief Kevin Feige Kevin is a
true Star Wars fan I think was something
like 20 something times in the theater
maybe 40 I don't remember but he loves
Star Wars that's on the fact that the
Guardians themselves are pretty obscure
in the public consciousness
mentha when was free to create Marvel's
very own Star Wars this one also had a
special place in my heart if you go with
Iron Man Thor Captain America Hulk all
these characters are pretty defined
people know what they are and guardians
nobody knew what guardians was it's very
niche and so what was great was it also
left it so that we could do a lot with
it if you upset some of the hardcore
fans maybe it's okay because there's not
as many of them you know what it did do
was allowed for a lot of exploration to
create Marvel Space Odyssey in 1976
writer bill Mantlo wrote a spacefaring
comic book story called the sword in the
star introducing a new character drawn
by Keith Giffen
akira-kun like the Beatles song not
rocket racoon because they didn't think
that gets sued for that anyway rocky
came back six years later with a new
design as Rocket Raccoon when montalais
was writing The Incredible Hulk the
character would come back again and
again over the years never really
straying from the core characteristics
Mantlo had given him at the starts these
attributes played a huge role in when's
design work for Rockets he explained the
important details he wanted to capture
when designing rockets he's impatient
he's got the little guy syndrome you
know the Napoleon syndrome definitely a
big man in a little body a big character
in a little body bursting out at the
seams he's always up to 11 when you look
at the concept art when created during
guardians of the galaxy's pre-production
Rockets huge personality comes through
clearly even the way he's standing
battle ready with a snarl on his face is
perfectly contrasted with groots
presence on the background and while
were on the subject of Groot and like
rocket Groot evolved significantly from
his comics debut in 1960 on the cover of
tales to astonish issue 13 a giant tree
monster named Groot from Planet X shows
up on a busy city street on earth daring
someone to fight him he returned as a
monster eleven years later to fight the
Hulk and finally started assembling our
peaceful heroic Groot when he appeared
in 2006 istic Fury's Howling Commandos
and 2007 annihilation conquest in the
latter series he seemed to develop the
friendship with rocky racoon that became
so central to the 2014 film in fact
according to when the Groot and Rocket
were two of the biggest question marks
going into the film's pre-production
period nobody this is gonna work you
know and and everybody was very nervous
about Groot and Rocket because the whole
movie was contingent upon those two
characters a tree in a raccoon
especially being integral part of that
five character team meanwhile when
contrasted this must topped great with
rockets fiery personality when asked
about the words had used to describe the
ideas he was trying to get across with
his early designs when said the
background tree when he needs to be but
he's a nice quiet
empathetic sympathetic addition to that
the quiet stream that keeps a peace
between all of them
star-lord has had plenty of looks over
the years there were a lot of them have
kept one constant from his appearance
way back in 1976 and up through his more
modern adventures in Marvel's guardians
of the galaxy team in 2007 star load
seems to like wearing some pretty weird
headgear when tried to capture the
elements in his concept art but the
design presented some headaches very
German World War two military the shape
of the helmet even slight the way the
pants are a lot of those certainly can't
really go for something that even the
color the blues we can't go for
something that's gonna harken back to
World War two Nazi uniforms it works
with Hydra right for Captain America
Hydra Red Skull that makes sense in
there villains the design work took a
positive turn Wentz writer director
James Gunn came on board once James came
in the retro cake back with the music
all that was very specific to James knew
really the tone and feel he wanted them
to feel like and so that was really
important oftentimes we don't always get
that and so James was much more specific
with like saying Peter Quill's gonna
have a tape deck that's important to him
so I'm like great that makes our job so
much easier already because that is a
visual cue that's what led to the
cinematic look the face mask and exposed
hair but the design communicated more
about the character than you might have
realized having his hair be exposed in a
way it's like some people were thinking
like how much does that actually do to
it to the character you're only showing
the hair and my golden hair actually
shows character if it's sort of like
kind of unkempt and all over you already
see part of that character Nova was
another important character from Marvel
Comics batch of cosmic stories in the
1970s though the version we got in
guardians of the galaxy didn't quite
resemble the earth-based superhero rich
rider who went by that name we didn't
have the super hero Nova as opposed to
at the Nova Corps
but just because Nova as a lone super
hero wasn't written into the script at
the time didn't mean he wouldn't make an
appearance in some fashion as part of
his explorations of marvel's characters
and designs when created some Novick on
that was inspired by rider super heroic
alter-ego to make sure the filmmakers
had as many options as possible I knew
at the time was like okay we'll probably
not gonna be having Nova's the lone
character at least it wasn't written in
I was sort of playing on that line just
in case so I did some takes where it's
more heroic it stands out more right as
like I'm a significant character that
needs to stand out but while when super
heroic version Nova didn't make it into
the film it's still pretty exciting to
know that his loss was John C Reilly's
gain hey star Prince star-lord
oh sorry Lord we did tons of takes and I
ended up doing this one that's more like
the military space police you know
because if that's what he serves so it
really ultimately just needs to serve
the stories it's got a codename it's
cool to have a Cody it's not that weird
check out one of our newest videos right
here
plus even more exclusive looper videos
with Charlie when about the creation of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]